One of the main things you
get out of using Analytics
is that you can see which parts
of your app your users are using.
When auto-tracking is enabled,
Analytics tracks usage of all activities
that are ended on the screen.
Analytics uses the term,
screen to mean an activity
that's displayed on the screen.
So here, this activity is rendered
as the Show Dinner screen.
You can name the screen specifically, or
you can let Analytics use the activity
class name as the screen name.
Here's what it looks like, if you
use the class names as screen names.
But here's how it looks,
if you assign you own screen names.
You specify screen names in
the tracking config file by using,
you guessed it, a screen name tag.
The name attribute is actually the name
of the class, complete with package.
It's not the name that shows
up in the Analytics dashboard.
The value of the tag is the name
that shows up in the dashboard.
Here we've got, Show recipe.
And here we've got, Show recipe.